he's here he's here where is he
I got to pull him up he says he's here
I gotta find his name alright people
that's yeah let's put in Kevin Smith
there is invite on screen we're getting
there
we're getting there boys and girls this
is gonna be very exciting with your
hosts it is Saturday night in Hollywood
so let's babble the [ __ ] on I'm Kevin
Smith
I'm Ralph Garman we're doing it we're
cyber what's up huh boss how are you my
friend
I'm hanging in there this is the first
time I would babble on that I'll be able
to not only smoke a joint but I'll be
rolling a joint as we speak see we can
make this a tutorial as well for the
kids at home I spent the most of the day
with our good friend and babbled brother
dr. Josh Roush shooting a bunch of video
for this upcoming project that I got
that I'm working on in stuff he sends
his best
well you know I love him let's hear it
for dr. Josh Roush you got [ __ ] sounds
and [ __ ] oh yeah baby you guys sound
bored oh yeah we have like Mozy [ __ ] we
can do karaoke son we're gonna do at the
Dingle we've got stuff to do stuff to
talk about material it's just like a
real babble you're gonna show your
Dingle is that what you said yes my dink
will be out later on this evening we are
of course on what is this crowdcast it
is crowdcast yes and we are also
simultaneously thanks to will Wilkins
the host of is
own show net heads and also our smog Co
tech guy he's streaming it on my youtube
and on my Facebook as well beautiful so
we got we got some eyeballs I don't
think anyone else is streaming tonight I
think it's just us we're happy we're the
only show in town Wow you think someone
would use the internet for entertainment
purposes they didn't figure out it's a
Saturday night this is a time people are
gonna be watching so you and me we got
this [ __ ] figured out man like those
other people the rest of Hollywood
morons they don't get it
Zach yeah as app indeed man is that
other streaming event which is much much
larger I only realize that today I was
like oh that's today's Gaga what do we
do now
yeah I didn't realize that either until
moments ago when is that begin I don't
know I assume it you ain't got a [ __ ]
change channel I'll give that [ __ ] right
here brah gah gah gah gah gah gah gah
I'm from Jersey I could do that [ __ ] is
he from Jersey I don't think so
hey no I think she spent some time there
oh no I remember early on in her career
when she was breaking I remember reading
article blah blah blah Jersey I was like
what oh I know a thing or two about that
state she's 19 gal so maybe the [ __ ]
kind of racist [ __ ] is that you're
like well she's a giant it's either
Italy or New Jersey there's a lot of
Italians in that part of the world is
all I'm saying
ladies and gentlemen I just disavow this
[ __ ] hate coming out of my partner's
mouth Hey Italian Americans without you
we wouldn't even have an America
I'm never going best beauty and Columbus
as well yeah we don't talk about him
anymore Yeah right back Amerigo Vespucci
um how are you man how is your
quarantine it is getting old I must say
you know I'm not out and about a ton
anyway because I do the Ralph's report
Monday through Friday which keeps me
indoors mostly
plug plug plug and I've been you know
working from home now for a couple years
so I spend the most of my time here
doing doing stuff but I miss restaurants
I miss bars I miss you know Carrie said
to me the other day when was the last
time we didn't go to a restaurant for
over a month and I can't think of the
last time in my life I haven't eaten out
so it's it's wearing thin on a lot of
people and a lot of people sadly are now
taking to the streets with goofy signs
saying it's against their rights and
things like that and we just all happy
here in Los Angeles yeah done in
Huntington Beach they had a big display
about a hundred people showed up with
signs saying this is socialism and
communism and it's the new world order
keeping us down and we want our rights
back and we want to be able to go back
to where it can go back to school and
they just don't understand science no
you sure you're not talking about
Florida this is California's well
California as well Huntington Beach here
it's been in Florida it's been in
Indiana
Virginia Minnesota there's been a lot of
people let me tell you something going
back to your point about restaurants as
of tomorrow here in Los Angeles
restaurant could come to you Ralph
because movies Sun right great pop-up
restaurant when the town opens back up
once all those Huntington protesters get
us our rights back Tom the folks that
did save by the max which was like I
Saved by the Bell restaurant and they
did good burger as well they're gonna be
doing a movies a pop-up movies where you
can actually go sit down
looks like movies inside everyone dress
wearing the outfits and [ __ ] full menu
including like cow tippers made it
beyond burgers will have like vegan and
non vegan stuff so that's down the road
but the good folks who put it all
together to say it by the max folks
we're like hey man we working with the
chef from secret lasagna right now you
wanted to a movies pop-up because we're
gonna use him for the chef when we do
the pop-up and stuff and we'll deliver
food and all the profits will go to know
us without them which charity that feeds
folks during the ghovat crisis and one
night so
I was like are you kidding me this is no
[ __ ] brainer so let me show you the
box all right this is the movie Meal box
wow that's awesome
it comes with a little like autograph in
it from me if you're into that sort of
thing but it comes with the lasagna
which movie's messy lasagna which either
vegan or non-vegan comes with hater tots
an order of tater tots tater tots has
seen in Jay and Silent Bob reboot and
for dessert chocolate-covered pretzels
from Mallrats
though from tomorrow for 19 until 4:00
26 April 26 you'll be able to order the
the movies meal like they only have a
few per day but and when they're gone
they're gone the word is that it's been
received so well that they're going to
do it in other cities as well across the
country which is really fun
particularly right now as everybody's
like you know every once in a while
something nice comes through and you're
like oh my gosh like water in the desert
you see the [ __ ] video of the
veterinarian waking up his deaf dog is
deaf blind dog and like that never
occurred to me that like you can't wake
a deaf blind dog without [ __ ] like
just giving her a [ __ ] heart attack
where's this guy he's blown on this
[ __ ] nose so sweet little [ __ ] like
that like kind of makes your day and
stuff so the movies pop up seem to play
very well with people and good calls as
well so it's gonna be fun man starting
tomorrow you can order that means on
4/20 Ralph my people's holiday I will
definitely be [ __ ] eating the movies
movies meals smoking some weed you're
gonna be a restaurateur though those
cats they just change their theme like
every two months or something like that
no so [ __ ] it delighted that they
invited me to do one because I'd always
read about the other are you there I'd
read about the other one would be like
man I wish I had a pop up movies I wish
they would do movies and one day they
did I know is a very first world kind of
wish like I wish I was a real live boy
so they eventually uh called me and they
were like hey you want to do this yes
[ __ ] yeah and this like movies meal is
only on post mates only in Los Angeles
from 419 to 426 but then we'll be taken
out apparently across the country lots
of people going like do it in [ __ ]
Jersey you idiot that's where you're
from we're working our way back east as
well but on 4/20 you can sit there and
eat a movie's meal I'm doing a live
watch along with Mallrats on Facebook on
4/20 as well Focus Features is doing
like hey watch me watch movies from our
old catalog and they get cool people
that talk about way cooler than me I
think they had Wes Anderson last week
and [ __ ] so I'm gonna be a real [ __ ]
come down from that I'm not gonna be
nearly as tweaked I'll tell you that
[ __ ] right now and they like that tweet
that Tweety spends Ralph oh they [ __ ] I
love that tweet the
you watch the the wonders get together
to watch that thing you do yesterday
nobody I know you did gives you're a big
[ __ ] fan of a fictional band and [ __ ]
if you love the waters the monkeys the
ready I love that movie and I love those
guys so cool to see them reunite talking
about the making of that film and Colin
Hanks we stopped by because he was
working on a with his dad back when they
were doing it and stuff a lot of inside
information all was really cool inside
baseball did they all look young they
look great all four look great Steve's
on his angels he looks exactly the same
he's just he was that [ __ ] movie
played at Sundance and it's sold for an
egregious amount of dollars and then did
no business sold to me romantics happy
Texas it was called
I remember well yeah co-leads and
whenever he went to [ __ ] fight he was
playing like a southern accent he had
that handlebar mustache and he would be
like the lad is green the new [ __ ]
attack he's wonderful actor
so it was did they sound like the movie
or is it that zoom version of like yeah
it was as well they didn't perform they
were just on hand to do a do a watch
along like you were talking about doing
with with Mallrats they just watched the
movie and gave you [ __ ] performed I
thought they all got together did that
thing with like four musicians in a room
and [ __ ] no it was just a wha that's
what I'm saying
hardly I was happy to see what the
spittle off my screen that's how mad I
would I'm for some reason I thought they
were singing a song they didn't they
weren't no they were reuniting to get
together to watch the movie along with
us the super fans well I'm gonna reunite
by myself and [ __ ] do them all that's
one I don't need my fake band behind me
your your your pal Kevin I'm gonna said
Nealon I want you to say Spacey [ __ ]
people like what no and pressure this
comedian actor was in red state
Sha Tin red snake Kevin come on the
scene with Goodman where he's one of the
ATF guys with Goodman and red state
committee and impressionist actor Kevin
Stephen root no I'm totally buggin Kevin
Pollak's oh yes Kevin [ __ ] of course
yeah he gets shot right up front holy
[ __ ] that's another Kevin involved in
red state it was the great Kevin [ __ ]
yes Kevin [ __ ] was also stopped by
because he was in that thing you do as
well and Giovanni Ribisi stopped by and
it was it was lovely
Gemma colic once told a very funny story
of going on The Tonight Show dressed as
Cupid where he went
it was the Carson Tonight Show and
Carson liked him when he was a comic so
he had him on a few times this is like
his fourth time or something so he
talked to Johnny Carson beforehand he's
like know where this Cupid outfit would
come out dressed like you because it was
Valentine's Day or something like that
and apparently Johnny was like if you
know yeah if you want to feel free
that's that's that'll be fun why don't
we if that's what you want to do if
that's what you want to do by all means
do it I can't I can't do I don't have a
car if you if you if you want to dress
his Cupid
feel free go go right go right ahead
that is [ __ ] fantastic
a man of [ __ ] at least twenty six and
a half impressions
Kevin something he was in red state I
can't remember so Johnny Carson says
yeah where'd a [ __ ] Cupid outfit and
the Kevin Pollak goes out you know
there's like Kevin Pollak and Kevin ball
comes out dressed like Cupid and it's
got like skin flesh tone to it and stuff
and the audience is like ah they sits
down and does a 10-minute couch piece
where after two minutes people are just
like is he still [ __ ] just like Cupid
because they're having a conversation
about his work or whatever and he's just
dressed in this ridiculous outfit and he
said that it taught him that like you
know it you better be better than
the outfit that's what he felt like the
advice Carson gave him was like it was
the outfit you know if it if it's
wonderful it'll take you the whole
segment but if not you're gonna be
sitting there wearing this [ __ ]
outfit and he was like for eight minutes
I was painfully aware of how I was
dressed on national television that's
great
great listen did you know that Kevin did
all the off-screen stuff for the actor
who played the judge in the courtroom
scene of a few good men wait I'm sorry
Kevin who Holly wait I understand wait
so he was not only playing Sam in the
movie they only had Nicholson for
another finite amount of time and they
got halfway through the last shooting
day it was time to let Jack go and Jack
had shot all of his coverage of that
scene where he's doing the big speech on
the on the jury and the witness stand
and it was time to let Jack go and so he
leaves and Pollock went to rob reiner
the director and said you know I know
this speech I've been sitting here
listening to Jack do it all week I know
it inside and out I can do Jack to the
other actor playing the judge if you
want to get his coverage you can shoot
over my shoulder and I'll do Nicholson
too and I'll do the speech as Nicholson
and that's how they got that coverage
for that guy
how can inconsiderate for that [ __ ]
actor the judge who's like I sat through
that [ __ ] you can't handle the truth
[ __ ] over and over again you mean to
tell me he's not gonna be there when I'm
just reacting to him I got like two
lines to him and though I'm not you're
gonna get Kevin Pollak and he's like
Kevin what kept movie tounging from Reds
big Wow look at that that's what you
come to Hollywood babble-on for kids
inside dope about the old-timers you
want to hear Carson's stories some two
guys who've never met him
Hollywood
and and an impression I I rarely get to
do because no one knows who Johnny
Carson is anymore I mean I thought about
the other days and well I guess you know
I said the other day says literally four
weeks ago I was in the valley and I was
going to veggie grill over there and I
passed you know Bob Hope's old estate
that giant ass like Bob Hope owns a town
in the middle of Toluca Lake right it's
huge the state of this place and you
know he's gone I think the Laura Scott
think they're all gone at this point he
must have some kids or something like
that but I was sitting there like who
has this house now whose house is it and
then it just sent me down the [ __ ] you
know rabbit hole of like Bob Hope was
one of the most famous [ __ ] human
beings on the planet like bigger than
faint I mean Fame nowadays is you know
[ __ ] a man I put up a funny tick-tock
like famous for 15 seconds and [ __ ] like
that this was a guy who was known all
around the world made [ __ ] huge
movies and [ __ ] like that
was one of the only like [ __ ] 28
entertainers in the business and [ __ ]
like that huge Hollywood legend had a
[ __ ] Nate Airport named after him but
where is he today you know I'm saying
there's no where's Bob Hope night or
[ __ ] like on the Bob Hope classics
let's go look back it talked about like
there's no hope on no there's no hope if
there's no hope for hope what hope do we
have they're gonna forget us 10 seconds
after we're [ __ ] dead let's be honest
they're gonna forget us before we
[ __ ] die what 10 seconds after we
stop this this broadcast it's all over
yes let's so let's babble the [ __ ] on
all weekend hey let's say let's talk
about some news shall we [ __ ] love
that
[Applause]
Jesus you don't [ __ ] hold back you're
just like let's start hard the scary way
let's get the bad news out of the way
and then move you gotta eat your
vegetables before you have your dessert
cap so true give them the bad news bears
I'm gonna lift my monitor up a little
bit
that's a sexier angle oh yeah no low
well first I'm going to 49 year old
double chin yeah dark
speaking of national treasures and
people that should be remembered Brian
Dennehy of course passed away this week
boy did I love his work Brian Dennehy
played amongst many other things John
Wayne Gacy that's right I forgot he did
that memorably also when I think of
Brian Dennehy a lot of people of course
like Rambo you dick I think if he was
amazing remember that Harrison Ford
movie a legit cool movie uh presumed
innocent yes loved that film he was so
good in that movie man he was wonderful
and I think Silverado remember he was
the sheriff where he's just like chill
out and I love that film and he is
brilliant in that for sure what do you
remember him from well Silverado is
probably my favorite performance of his
but also when I was I was in New York
years ago and I just had a wild hair up
my ass I wanted to go see a Broadway
play I want to see a matinee and I got
tickets for Death of a Salesman
starring Brian Dennehy as Willy Loman
and obviously the guy was a great film
actor but him on stage was a force of
nature I'll never forget that
performance blew me away because he was
such a man of size - you know he was a
big guy and live on stage you know you
think of Willy Loman it's sort of like a
schlubby character and you know he sees
a beaten-down old salesman and he's
usually played by slight men but this
size Dennehy playing him with such power
and the same time such pathos it was
just it was remarkable so whenever I
think of him I just I flash back to that
a lot of cats in our chat right now are
going
a fax you [ __ ] fools absolute oh yes
he was amazing not just one but two FX
movies man
where's Brian Brown now next great where
is he I wish we had some sort of magical
device that would tell us where people
are and who they are what happened to
them I don't know one day perhaps brain
over here in the chat was reminded me of
Patton Oswalt's story about Brian
Dennehy what is it
he and Dennehy were at the same party
and danny he was just just going to work
on the buffet and Patton was talking to
him he and Patton was trying to lose
some weight and then he said aren't you
going to eat his now I'm trying to lose
a couple pounds and he said fool it's
the beauty being a character actor we
can get as fat as we want and just keep
working leading men have to worry about
that stuff not guys like us eat up and
he was of course Tommy Boy that's
something we don't
we didn't ease and Tommy boy's name he's
Farley's dad in that was dead
that was not I've seen it but that's not
I wasn't a I was making flicks then so I
wasn't like into into the Farley catalog
I saw him Albans but I forgot he was an
app but for a lot of people to like what
are you [ __ ] kidding using Tommy Boy
like modern-day classic absolutely right
what a great actor he was man a lot of
range he could do anything it was it
wasn't Corona was it no I think was Hart
I got the paperwork here but those says
that natural causes there will not be an
official autopsy at 81 so I guess just
gave out
oh my god somebody wrote in a few
seconds thank you Ryan Dennehy in foul
[ __ ] play son he was Chevy Chase's
friend I think the cop friend oh right
that's how far he goes back and I love
foul play
how the [ __ ] and with all due respect to
Brian Dennehy a huge giant he will be
missed
huge bucket of wind
one of the greatest character actors
this world has ever [ __ ] known that
all being said how the [ __ ] has nobody
remade foul play yet don't give them any
ideas such a great movie can't play seek
it out Goldie Hawn and Chevy Chase young
Chevy Chase young gold leon burgess
meredith the [ __ ] penguin for those
of you in the garmi and whatnot or he
was one tough old mama
who else Dudley Moore an early Dudley
Moore film and the appearance as the
conductor that's right even before the
Blake Edwards stuff like yes he had done
like him and what is it more in cook
yeah Pete yeah the young more in [ __ ]
right okay but he was pretty much
unknown in the States and this was a
foul play is what broke him
wow man that's wild yeah Brian Dennehy
was in that he was chubby chasers
Catherine God no [ __ ] reliable and he
was absolutely right in terms of like
you could look like that and work like
crazy and he did he worked his whole
[ __ ] life you look at his eye on TV
page it's longer than Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
keeping an on brand love it and besides
people passing in show business we also
have people helping you always need one
so many people doing so much good stuff
to help out with Koba 19 relief are you
following this all in challenge no what
is it all in challenge calm our
celebrities who are putting up
interesting experiences and items kind
of like Oh maze does where if you donate
a certain amount of money you put they
put your name and a hopper and if they
pull it out then you win the a lot of
big-time celebrities are putting stuff
together to put in this all and
challenge and then they
to recommend that another celebrity
friend of theirs gets involved and so it
keeps snowballing and the dominoes keep
falling and more and more cool things
are showing up when you say big
celebrities like give me an example I
was going to talk about the one I want
to win which is Leonardo DiCaprio and
Robert DeNiro have gotten together and
they are offering a walk-on role in the
new Scorsese film killers of the flower
moon that they're going to be filming
once this Kovach thing is over so if you
win you get to spend the day on the set
with those three guys you will be in a
scene with De Niro and DiCaprio and then
you also get an invite to the world
premiere they'll fly you out you can be
at the premiere and walk the red carpet
all that stuff all right so much how
much all you have to do is donate the
minimum amount they're trying to get as
many people's like a lottery get as many
so it's not like I could bid [ __ ]
$200,000 if I was crazy rich and I win
it's like honoré it's not an auction
it's like a lottery which is what amazed
those two they figure they can make more
money by selling multiple tickets for
ten bucks a pop rather than just
counting on one person to outbid
everyone else for a couple hundred grand
or whatever so I'm gonna stop you right
there look up clean these nostrils are
those are pretty good nostrils yeah
thank you is that we've introduced two
now that's entertainment entertainment
checking out you're checking out your
sinuses so wait so so that's pretty
sweet all right
that's the gun Oh like Matthew
McConaughey he's putting some stuff in
Ellen DeGeneres has an event where you
can come to her show you're taking some
[ __ ] hits last few weeks you see that
what did you see what she said when she
started crying in her mansion about
being oh like this is like being in
prison and I'm like yeah you live in a
giant beautiful house with huge picture
window it was like Shh about telling
death she was crying be fair like you
know she comedians trying to be funny
and stuff and well the driver she was
crying she was in tears really I didn't
watch no no
was like it's like being in jail she's
not literally crying and being like
who's like prison rattled about being
quarantined yes I mean look you know I
in her and she ain't me obviously and
stuff and she got way different life but
I know for a fact that my house isn't
nearly as big or as nice as hers and I'm
very content to like stay home and stuff
and she sex with Portia de Rossi
whenever he wants
forgot about the sound like it's animate
she's how old these big Ellen is I would
have to say she's 62 unbelievable I
never would have imagined she was 62
years old I don't have no idea let me
look it up you're right she is 62 she is
not in one of the articles with her like
everyone's mad at Ellen Ellen comma 62
and I couldn't dance to anything else
cuz I'm like that's what 62 looks like
I'll take a big bucket as [ __ ] 60 -
ladies and gentlemen I thought like 62
was my grandmother when I was growing up
and she did not look healthy or as
vibrant she didn't dance out of [ __ ]
talk show every day but like she didn't
she was old looking Ellen looks like
she's our age yeah well more age than
yours yeah what I mean
no I think she looks like honestly well
number one I don't think we look all
that [ __ ] you think you look that
much older than me yeah did you hear my
jersey come out you think you look older
than me yo look older than me you go
chipped my Jersey gypsymichelle what you
think you look older than me I look
older didn't [ __ ] you
it's [ __ ] guy you don't know um
yeah anyway back to how do we get to
Ellen in the first place because she's
part of this all in challenge.com so if
you're interested in finding out what
they have what is she doing she's like
come to my Jail
bring me a pie and slide it through the
bars
I think she's something you get to go
and behind-the-scenes at her talk show
or something when they go back to
product I would try to win that because
I've never
been on our talk show if that's one of
the prizes I'm gonna try to win it she
was she has never had me on her show
granted like you know she's got huge
[ __ ] favors people I see some people
on that show that I like oh those people
could be on the show would not be a lot
less famous than you to show you get to
decide who comes on your show yeah maybe
she just doesn't like you she doesn't I
know that for a fact she her and not
port now she's with Porsche but who is
Anne Heche Annie old show favorite Anne
hates when she was dating a nation or
together with that hey chasing amy was
out and they went to see it and left in
the first 10 minutes because you're a
sis white male trying to represent the
lesbian persona we didn't have those
terms back then but yeah essentially
they walked in there like this is
written by a [ __ ] dude and like
[ __ ] all these guys are dudes this is
like [ __ ] this movie and wisely didn't
spend her time on it but I only know
that because the Miramax folks at the
time were just like you know she was
super famous because she had come out
and stuff and they were like you know
the world's most well known lesbian is
about to see your lesbian move and she's
[ __ ] gone don't worry about it never
mind moving oh no robbers fan yeah we
did not get approval whatsoever the
other one I was always hoping for more
Joey than makers Joey like loved the
Rosie O'Donnell show so she was really
hoping to get on the Rosie O'Donnell
show but I think that might have been
before rosie was necessarily out as well
so I don't know if she wanted to
necessarily show Kate show you something
I think years later Joey did get on the
show I don't know I can't remember that
but I remember Rosie O'Donnell show was
huge at the time and you know we were
like oh my god can't we like get Joey on
there man she loves that show and there
was a kind of like well I don't know if
I can't remember if she was out at that
point or not but like I think the idea
was she don't want to talk about this
but not believe me this is not I don't
know I mean I know Rosie a little bit
a little bit and she's really really
[ __ ] cool I don't know
Ellen at all but and that's my only
that's the closest I've ever come to
Ellen DeGeneres other than whenever I
Drive past [ __ ] the Warner Brothers
law and her audience is letting out and
trying to cross the street I've not
heard bad things about her from anybody
I've ever worked with but recently I saw
a couple articles where I was like what
the hell I am Ellen DeGeneres and I
shared the same pet store we used to go
to the same pet store when I lived in
Hollywood and we we were married no this
is when I just had gotten married with
Carrie I had a house in Hollywood before
we moved to the valley and we got Reggie
first together
and so it was a puppy we used to go to
this high-end pet store because it was
the nearest one to us and the guy who
became very close friends with us and he
was also the pet storage of the stars I
guess apparently but he did a lot of
work for Ellen DeGeneres and had some
nightmare stories about dealing with her
really I find you can learn at so much
about some especially celebrity by how
they treat people that they they they
frequent as customers you know I think
that is so telling how they treat the
help in other words you can tell a lot
about people and he would tell stories
that raise the hair on the back your
head just one of the reasons that I took
50% no matter where my brother who works
in the food service industry hates that
he's like why do you do that he's going
it's not right
like like especially like will be out to
eat someplace and he's just like that
service sucked you cannot [ __ ] do 50%
and I'm like I will never not do good
percent number one I worked in the food
service industry as a busboy and I only
got 15% of the waitresses tips right I
know that trickled [ __ ] down and I
appreciated my tips at the end of the
night as a [ __ ] busboy so you know I
don't I don't know I'm not a biblical
person that much anymore Ralph but I was
raised on the Bible then there's Palin
there's benders best passes
comes back to samples so the moment I
had [ __ ] salute to gab and [ __ ] once
I had a career like I am a 50% tipper in
restaurants number one because I worked
in them but number two because you don't
ever want people telling those N Ellen
DeGeneres stories behind your back man
like you know going like oh I fired
dealt with that guy he's a piece of [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying like I treat
everybody like they're [ __ ] you or
Scott Mosier or my daughter and [ __ ] to
the point where my wife gets irritated
which is like you know like you give
people a lot more time and I'm like I
can't but man like everyone I learned
from the best
Stan Lee everybody has to have the most
like impressive interaction with you
because that might be the only
interaction you ever get with them and
you can only leave that [ __ ] taste
for that moment you never want to
disappoint and not be who they think you
are you know what I'm saying so
obviously I'm baked
over to you wrong you're out of sync
somehow you're on a delay office not me
you had on some audio problems and now
you're you're out of sync with your with
your audio should I jump off and jump on
sorry about that folks but that we can
still hear him but that would be super
annoying so we're not going to do that
let me pull him back boom boom there he
is invite on screen he'll be back with
us in a second and then more tales of
people in Hollywood helping other people
hello can hear I can hear you can you
see good you're beautiful again you're
beautiful
I want all Ironman for a second there
you did also Hollywood helpers you may
know something about this apparently the
new jersey pandemic relief fund is
raising some money
this month I made a video for them a
couple of two weeks ago or something in
my of my living room with Jersey map as
the background they're doing an event
called Jersey for Jersey and it's going
to be a musical comedy event that's
going to be broadcast on April 22nd yeah
Apple music and Apple TV and Sirius XM
and some other local stations there on
the East Coast including WABC in New
York and a bunch of other places so if a
live thing is april 27 7 p.m. they go in
live with music and comedy from such
notable Jersey i'ts as the boss Bruce
Springsteen jahres Jovi of course
Holly quality a Jersey girl I didn't
know that ooh Halsey H al se why they
singer she really from New Jersey I'm
guessing it seems like everybody else is
Danny DeVito I know is he's on board
Kelly Ripa Jon Stewart Whoopi Goldberg
Chelsea Handler
he's from New Jersey Whoopi Goldberg
yeah I never knew that who always after
Chelsea Handler and it of course yeah
they got a lot of high-end just keep
waiting for Kevin Smith no I don't see
that name on this list no by the copious
turning of pages Ralph that my name does
not appear on that list yes so so why do
you hate Jersey why won't you raise
money for Jersey I don't understand
why'd you turn them down don't put it
like that they haven't reached out to me
yeah I'm kidding of course yeah that's
true digging up hopefully well there's a
few days left I'm not the kind of guy
that reach out to anybody else I don't I
don't function that way and not because
I'm like I just like I don't do that so
people ask me to do things I'm like oh
my god absolutely but I would never
reach out and be like can I can I come
to your New Jersey party like I left
that life behind a long time ago the
kind of life where I have to ask
somebody to be involved in something
yessum is they reach out I'm thuggin
they're a heartbeat I hope they do they
reached out for the for the video but
you know
I'm no Danny DeVito we know this Ralph
speaking of things that we're doing
virtually to raise money I saw that
you're also on board next weekend with
the virtual comic-con that's going and
skipping I'm all for a calm where I
don't have to leave the house
you can't be the first con run be
sitting there on the Conn jerking off
nobody will know like yeah you need the
Jane saw a bob reboot man it was like a
blast from the past
I think they'll know if you're doing
that I can be better
hi this is gonna be fun I guess I'm
hoping I assume somebody smarter than me
will organize something similar for San
Diego in July now that that doesn't
exist we should have done that in tinsel
town stiffs man Comic Con for the first
time in 50 years cancelled crazy but so
I'm sure there'll be another virtual
Connor on them but what is this one call
that I'm doing are you doing it as well
yeah they asked me to come on and I'm
moderating a panel with my buddy Seth
Green from Robot Chicken and Family Guy
so we're gonna doing that together in a
alternate reality j2 my Silent Bob well
that's right yeah that's easy I wanted
him the other person Universal like
Breckin Meyer also a Robot Chicken tier
yeah indeed the name of that is I don't
have alpha I'll find well then we'll
tweet it out I forget I shouldn't have
brought it up without knowing but it's
gonna be fun
yeah and so I saw you were your name
listed also in the celebrity guests
we'll be doing that next week and on
Saturday I think it is Hollywood helpers
abound Ralph indeed what's its name John
Krasinski like look DJ a prom last night
or something yeah that's what I heard on
his good news show get that guy back to
work cuz I don't want to compete with
him he's [ __ ] charm sitting he's
streaming all over the internet and
[ __ ] like hey man good news look it's
the guys from the office and [ __ ] I
can't compete with that
it's work let him make those quiet
movies and [ __ ] because I I like this
space for my
John thank you very much there's way too
many people crossing over into the
podcast world for my liking as well
that's been happening for so long I
don't but like 13 year podcast veteran
so I've watched all the
johnny-come-lately move in and stuff
speaking of johnny-come-lately if i
could def join Instagram yesterday two
days ago for the first time his first
social media he's ever done Wow
I don't get 24 hours he had more
followers than I have on Instagram
that's [ __ ] that's power boy that's
strength that's power
pictures of scarves I think he will get
to that but his first videos and just
sitting there going never done this
before click good for him though
I'll give him a place to talk about
famous people not taking advantage of
social media it's like don't you want to
tell your story like they caught up argh
you know I was doing this [ __ ] since 95
on the view askew message board and
people like I remember Joey would make
fun of me all the time going like oh my
god are you going to play with your
pretend friends on the web now and now
everybody plays with their pretend
friends on the web now all of our
friends are on the web I have any
real-life friends anymore
no way nothing this this lockdown time
it is time to talk about some show
business headlines starting with this
series on the peacock streaming service
they familiar with peacock yes where's
George Carlin said I'm familiar with the
peak hunt quasi said he didn't say that
he said one of his jokes was you know
what they call a female peacock I'll be
[ __ ]
I am familiar with this service peacock
it is where the office is gonna go and
that is their driver yeah apparently the
kids today and I know this from my kid
downstairs love the office room
it's the way that we loved whatever
reruns we loved and [ __ ] I don't know
that I ever loved reruns it's just what
we had like it was like all right we'll
watch The Brady Bunch because that's all
you're giving us I'm sure but in the age
of streaming you can like [ __ ] watch
your show over and over my kid goes to
sleep to the office it's her comfort
blanket so they're counting on the
office to be the driver for this peacock
but to me the secret weapon is its
universal as well so that means like the
same way HBO max is like hey JJ Abrams
is doing Overlook Hotel
on HBO max spin on shining or Justice
League dark at HBO max HBO Max is like
here man make crazy movies here because
look at what Netflix did look what
Disney Plus did do that [ __ ] [ __ ]
here so they're gonna spend copious
amounts money I'm hoping Universal feels
the same way man because then I'm gonna
walk in there and be like I got three
words for you for twilight of the
Mallrats put it right on that [ __ ]
peacock app man so you know that would
get a few people who like my [ __ ] to
show up yeah so I'm all for this peacock
cam please don't tell me like welcome
they just killed it you know initially
it was going to be just NBC Universal
reruns as you mentioned they're old back
catalogue and fiat films and stuff like
that but they're gonna starting now to
invest in a ton of original programming
and the one that caught my eye is
they're doing an eight-episode
miniseries about the life of Angeline
which i think is genius yeah so whose
planner I just saw a picture emmy rossum
yeah shameless
she's the trailer and I was like god
dammit this is a genius idea how did no
one explore this character before she's
fascinating and it's a great little
slice of life and it's a great time
period and you know in LA history and
the Sunset Strip and all that stuff so I
think it's gonna be awesome yeah that'll
make me look I was getting that app
anyway I didn't get Quigley and I'm not
saying [ __ ] kwibi but like nothing about
kwibi grabbed me but I've been getting
that peacock app for sure you're not
alone I mean Quimby's numbers still
aren't what most entertainment streaming
services are getting initially when they
first opened up and I think it's like a
90 day free trial period even
that's not getting people to sign up
it's I mean I don't I did there's just I
looked at like what they had to offer
and there was nothing that like spoke to
me where I'm I go she had I need to
watch that and stuff I'm sure I'll get
around to it sooner or later all I need
is one good buzzy little show where I'm
like oh [ __ ] I pick up a [ __ ] kwibi
well you know that was a tough launch in
the midst of all this which like one
part of their app like you know they
want their [ __ ] living on the phone so
right now we're all home and everybody
can stream from their phones to the TV
so they couldn't even watch their kwibi
on the TV so that was frustrating people
when they see just bad timing across the
boards but I don't know maybe it'll
bounce back although I did read an
article where it dropped in the iTunes
App Store although it was number 11 in
the Android store it dropped down to
like number 75 in the iTunes App Store
so get your kwibi why ken kids they
paint a ton of money those people to
produce content for that to Spielberg
and others I mean everybody's getting
getting richer I wish that some of that
[ __ ] kwibi money would be amazing
this is a pretty cool story it could
have been a Hollywood help her but I
saved it for headlines
Tom Hardy's returning to the BBC
children's channel c-beams as it's
called and CBeebies rather CBeebies and
they are having him in this time of
kovat crisis read bedtime stories to
kids at the end of april one a night
from April 27th of May 1st so Tom Hardy
will be once again reading British kids
to bed which is how [ __ ] terrifying
chilling there's a lovely singing voice
I don't know why here Tom Hardy reading
green eggs and ham to my kid at night
but he can't seem to like it when their
dreams law and bashes they do about the
bishop to sleep did you ever see him in
legend where he played both Kray twins
the British
gangsters I thought that was great film
but he was great have you seen the
trailer for the Capone movie the Josh
Trank directed yeah bond zone
it's called Capone yeah I'm in and
[ __ ] all of them I watch anything
that that he does yeah we found a guy
Josh Trank I don't know I mean I'm gonna
I'm there for track man [ __ ]
Chronicle is a type movie yeah Fantastic
Four it just sounds like sometimes
things just don't pan out but but I you
know this is a story about Capone's life
I don't know so like in my head because
the is that stupid I am because the
untouchables I was like oh he died in
jail like they put him in jail for tax
evasion and that was that apparently
[ __ ] got out lived in Florida and
some [ __ ] yeah with syphilis rotting his
brain
yeah I've seen I was thought that was in
jail but apparently no apparently not no
I'm glad it's [ __ ] streaming man I
mean I'll be honest with you I I know
like movie studios and [ __ ] are like oh
my god I hope we get to take these
bigger movies out soon because nobody
wants to stream you know like a Chris
Nolan's new movie tenant nobody wants to
stream Black Widow and [ __ ] like just
send it home they need those big big
movie theatre experiences makes buku
buck on those movies so you know the
fact that they are putting any movies
out like for home release and stuff like
that one that just I'm like you got my
money I'll totally [ __ ] pay to see
that because I would have paid [ __ ]
three times that if I took my wife and
bought some food at the [ __ ] cinema
if you will so I know this is not what
the movie industry that particularly the
theatrical exhibition industry wants
like you know the idea of everyone
getting comfortable with watching big
movies first-run release movies at home
but like after this the world is gonna
be very different and right now we have
gotten used to like oh that was just in
a theater now I'm watching it here
interest for sure you know when when
Capone first went to jail the first time
around he went to jail and in it brides
Burt which is a prison just outside
Philadelphia and my grandfather was
working with Paramount Pictures at the
time and Capone lived like a king on the
inside paid off all the guards had
fully furnished cell with the couch and
chairs and tables and he would pay my
grandfather to bring him prints of film
and they would scream them in prison so
Capone could watch the movies you should
me so you got connection to Capone and
[ __ ] my grandfather used to bring films
into prison so Capone could watch them
did you get yourself checked for
syphilis yeah let me ask you some of the
men like this format is so no pressure
like one more in front of 200 people
it's like we better be [ __ ] funny
here we're like literally just I'm like
before I'm like losing my nationals like
buggin its notes you got notes you're
like I got notes and when the show's
over you're in a [ __ ] here I'm all
Smith and woman no more nostrils number
two shut the [ __ ] up and let me talk but
it's that way on all the shows when you
watch Kimmel and and Colbert and Fallon
and Bill Maher doing the D HBO show from
his home it's just chain it's a
different animal it's just changes
everything
yeah it's so weird to watch them do
monologue jokes train to wait for laughs
and stuff yeah it's it's funny it's an
education for them for all those cats
are like having to essentially learn to
do like this rather than polished
there's a cue card over there feeding me
every [ __ ] line right live HBO is
better says Bridgette from Long Island
of course it is from Long Island
everything
[Music]
because you know a little [ __ ]
Justin Bieber in the news he subscribed
and surprised his fans at a virtual
concert they all got together on online
at at Bieber virtual concert and they
were all playing Bieber's music for each
other in a giant chat room and Bieber
actually showed up and serenaded his
fans with a backing track
some say sounding rather poorly
performing for the for his fans but I
guess at least he showed up what kind of
what kind of tune in you think of Justin
Bieber gets at this point still a
million right at least it doesn't say
how many people packed the room because
it wasn't it was fan created it wasn't
it what he what he was doing so everyone
was surprised when he should have
apparently he caught wind of this event
and they just decided to pop in and
surprise everyone and then he was gone
but I mean here we sit [ __ ] Craig
anonymous for the cats who are in that
[ __ ] room you know they were like are
you [ __ ] serious
is it him but apparently did not sound
great of course he was singing over the
computer I got to give him that but
still I hope a lot of people were like
show us your dick
show us your tats yeah take your dick
out is your dick have tats on it oh my
god if your des de beber shows your deck
that's the only way I believe it was
Justin Bieber was it on what that was he
seen like it was a zoo me kind of thing
yeah yeah he was singing with a backing
track on zoom on he was simulcasting and
he just popped into the room and people
lost their minds everybody doing their
part good I got some geek news you wanna
go through that Bach yeah Ralph and
Kevin Ralph and Kevin - Kevin
[Music]
Chris just asked me to show I said shows
your dick keV well not yet people got
very excited there for a minute please
no dicks dude I take that personally
somebody was might want to see my dick
Jennifer maybe you don't but might
somebody might nobody wants to see mine
what do you got there bet a bathrobe is
that what you're rocking tonight Rock
like every moment that I'm in this house
I'll be honest with you not every moment
if I wasn't on a live stream I probably
wouldn't be wearing the bathrobe we
started I thought it was a sports code
then when you stood up I was like I
think he's wearing a bro
that's the longest sport code I've ever
seen a duster
he's from the left he's wears his fedora
yeah I know it's it's a waffle robe man
a leftover from the from the casual male
big and tall stores so I like a long and
robe that I can swim in and [ __ ] look
like a drape look you know I look like I
look like I go to school of Harry
Potter's Hogwarts like a caftan yes
that's what I'm looking for I got rid of
my hockey jerseys but I won't get rid of
this something flowy so you can when you
walk down the stairs it flows behind you
can tell you somethin I didn't know to
graze I'd fasted for two days I thought
good sure it is it absolutely is fine
but the first thing I ate which was like
maybe three hours ago was a beyond
burger that I made myself and it I put
nothing on it I just ate that [ __ ] like
just cooked plain and it was perhaps one
of the most satisfying meals I've ever
had in my life
the key to enjoying food is not to
[ __ ] eat it constantly like you know
only 48 hours men and but oh my god I
was so [ __ ] like this is amazing I
had a new appreciation for it so it was
[ __ ] yummy now I'm probably gonna
take tomorrow off on the fast tomorrow
and then I'll have a burger on Monday
you are already doing intermittent
fasting what's this now day the days of
not eating it's still intermittent
ambience I was inspired by you Ralph
came over the houses of the show and
Ralph looks [ __ ] good man like Ralph
looks divorced guy good that's what I
couldn't [ __ ] tell that alright I got
it I got a spruce up the old Chaffee the
dude is ready to sling some these guy
he's got some boyfriend dick to sell
ladies a gentleman so he's got a [ __ ]
put himself in order and [ __ ] like that
so I saw him I was like ah [ __ ] man I
reminds me I should be [ __ ] I should
be intermittently fasting more than I
was particularly during lockdown I was
just like it's breakfast let's get ice
cream
you know vegan ice cream it's still ice
cream nonetheless so now you know I've
kind of gotten it under control
I'm literally just five pounds away from
where I was when I left to go on tour so
I'm feeling pretty good about [ __ ] so
your your fasting days at a time just to
get yourself back to your goal weight
yeah in combination with hiking like I
can't go to Runyon anymore but it's
there's a hill near me I could walk all
the way up to Mulholland Drive and it's
one mile straight up there's pretty good
workout daily without like killing
yourself or anything like that it's
pretty good work on that walk with dog
and stuff so I've lost like Lucy said
seven pounds this week and you know two
of those days were from it I was there I
had intermittently fasted three days
Wednesday then I ate Thursday know
Tuesday then I didn't eat Wednesday then
eight then I did I ate Wednesday then I
didn't need Thursday and Friday and then
I just finally ate today and it's not
that difficult again when you've got
extra weight when your body's got fat to
be eating that's stored energy and [ __ ]
right it's not like oh it's tearing my
muscles apart and [ __ ] it's it's [ __ ]
just starts eating all the [ __ ] fat
so I'd step on a scale man and like I
see results you are a disciplined man
when you put your mind to it your rock
sometimes yes and that's what it was
about all that last week I was just like
I must be more disciplined and I got
more disciplined but seeing you like
helps because I was like he looks
[ __ ] good I should be looking that
[ __ ] good you do mm-hmm
five pages and five pounds of waiting on
[ __ ] and I'm let me see 80 I'm on page
81 of Twilight at the mall rat so I'm
like 20 to 30 pages away from finishing
the second version of mall rats I've
ever written Wow well rat sequel I've
ever written being productive Ralph
trying to keep busy good man
speaking of productions ABC has
announced they are moving the fondant
season of agents of shield up to May
because they don't have any programs so
they're taking their summer slate and
they're moving it up now to spring
because they don't have any merchandise
to put on their airwaves they're putting
their game shows that they usually run
during the summer like match game and
press your luck and Family Feud and that
stuff that's also coming out in the main
and the last season of agents of shield
which I love is going to be debuting in
May as well so how many seasons that
they get to with agents of shield thanks
Evan I want to say seven maybe it's more
and you've watched every one of them
yeah
storm Raven says get a room you two hey
hey hey hey just because I can admire
man's physique that's right Shaun
Porteous says what am i drinking this is
is gonna little be little bougie but
it's Perrier strawberry essence there's
zero calories for some reason I as an
older gentleman I've fallen in love with
bubbly seltzer give me a social
sub-sahara that's what they used to
drink and their old times
holy [ __ ] man those good drinks can you
entertain the folks for like a refill my
glass absolutely
I had some questions here and stuff
let's see they were going to podcast in
the process of Gordon that rules once
you're smoking cap thank you
right now I'm smoking my good ol hold on
I'm coming back
snoo guns caviar go look at that Silent
Bob on the weed you know you can trust
it and your face is on the packaging and
stuff I'm smoking that man's and then
two good hits hard and I like trying to
work through it
we did a lot of shooting on video today
me and Josh Roush for this new project
that we got starting on Monday on 4/20
now it's look for you see well I mean go
to my Twitter go to my Instagram but we
got something cool that we're announcing
and now comes Monday right yeah
and it affects Ralph's man as well and I
mean I've got an announcement that's
gonna go along with his until coincide
and I've seen my thing that we're
announcing and there is a throw to your
thing beautiful so that's gonna be good
I trust we've been vague enough for this
audience I think so
mmm it's been a project that we've been
building over here for a red-hot minute
and it came to fruition at absolutely
the right time and stuff but yes it's
going to have a big effect on people who
like my stuff and your stuff as well yes
Joe van says Ralph and Kevin are
announcing their nudes on Monday to help
raise money for charity no that won't be
over
you would have to lift up the flabby
skin pouches that used to be my [ __ ]
gut that hang over my [ __ ] pubes
oh do you hear that the doing all that
banging and yelling for eight o'clock
400 to pay tribute to the frontline
workers to the frontline workers you can
hear like
so crazy you can hear from like down not
downtown but like down the hill and so
there people have got kids in the
neighborhood and that is a total kid
pastime like we're gonna go out of date
o'clock tonight we're gonna yell for the
first oh my god that's right up a
[ __ ] kids alley that's guys stuff a
kid remembers man like [ __ ] years
from now and these people are [ __ ] 50
kids would be like I remember going out
and banging on a pot and yelling out for
the front line workers and stuff like
that
and now taking all these details because
this is a moment in history that you're
going to be talking about for the rest
of your life your good dads you're
saying that that's very smart
yeah here we got more deep news you're
gonna like this I haven't gotten off
board yet still but they're doing an
eight-episode docu-series over there on
Disney Plus about the making of the
mandalorian because they haven't got
enough blood out of that stone yet so
we're watching it I still haven't
watched it know I'm getting a lot of
grief from the garmi because I have yet
to sit down and like look dude I know
interest in your honor [ __ ] but legit
it's wonderful and I came to it late so
I had to sit there and try to watch it
after everyone was like baby Yoda like I
bought our fog car right and it lived up
to the hype it was beyond enjoyable I
had some of the best [ __ ] times
watching
mandalorian like that was right at the
top of the of the quarantine premieres
right after I got home from from the
tour all right so I loved it it was so
[ __ ] what if I guarantee you you will
love it it is like remember the Planet
of the Apes TV show from the 70s
yes feels exactly like that then I'm in
Ghana I'm telling you you're gonna be
like holy [ __ ] like you will fall in
love with Star Wars again it's just Dave
Filoni and Jon Favreau particularly Jon
Favreau created the show and wrote a lot
of the episodes of [ __ ] when I saw fabro
at the rise of Skywalker premiere I
hadn't seen Mandalorian and I was like
hey man Congrats [ __ ] like they all
they keep doing is talking
about mandalorian and stuff he gave me a
you know challenge corn and stuff but I
said whoo baby Eau de [ __ ] sweeping
the nation who came up with that because
I did and I was like really good I wrote
the show when I was like did you I
thought he just directed or something
like this so I'm oh it's [ __ ]
wonderful like baby baby Yoda lives
beyond by it's so [ __ ] good like they
use them just enough and [ __ ] it's
adorable it's tactile but the whole
thing feels every episode especially you
even the credits at the end feels like
you're watching Planet of the Apes TV
show on like wor or you know some
syndicated champ P IX right you know on
a Saturday afternoon at like 3 o'clock
and [ __ ]
oh it's wonderful it's the best review I
could get well Disney Plus is doing an
eighth episode docu-series called Disney
gallery the mandalorian which promises
to take you behind the scenes which have
no [ __ ] Kristen that no I would watch
that some of it I don't know do you like
watching behind the scenes [ __ ] I do I I
make it like now that I make it I'm not
as interested in behind the scenes like
it's tough for me to be like oh let me
see they're making of cuz yeah I got a
really love something hardcore if I'm
gonna watch the making up cuz I know how
this stuff is made now but I'm
interested in the stories of the people
involved in the creative process not
necessarily you know the making of
footage and an e BK stuff and everything
but I love when people tell stories
about experience what they experienced
while working on something that I really
appreciate so there that aspect I would
be interested I think making of Joss
somebody said Sean Porteous you know you
don't have to shout out [ __ ] to make me
wrong but you're absolutely right I
would watch the [ __ ] out of the making
of Jaws I'd watch a TV show about the
making of Jaws they should dramatize
that it's such a [ __ ] matron I mean
look
peacock bro peacock we should put the
peacock the story I'll use
Carl what's-his-name a bleep car got
leaves the jaws log cuz they're making a
musical based on it some plight you just
do that the making of jokes it's an epic
story and of itself its period you got a
real drunk guy you got a director who's
[ __ ] gonna lose it all because the
movie goes like a year over schedule and
[ __ ] three four times over budget
shark wolf [ __ ] work man
oh my god it's you get ten episodes out
of that easy
you're drunk I am I'm like I'm like
Robert Shaw drunk and [ __ ] I'm like hey
hey Dreyfuss good [ __ ] out of here
that's my Irish ex exit do you know he
was a playwright as well Robert Shaw
yeah man in the glass Tollbooth yes well
well done multi-talented that guy indeed
yes so anyway for you mandalorian fans
Disney gallery the mandalorian starts on
oh of course it starts on May the 4th is
when the first episode will be available
JC JC at scum and villainy Cantina in
Los Angeles you know they're still
closed of course as is every place but
on May the fourth he's doing a live
stream from the cantina for 24 hours for
may the 4th because May the fourth was
like they're [ __ ] you know Mother's
Day is the biggest restaurants it was
their mother's day plus Christmas like
they had a line out the bar it started
they started like [ __ ] 6:00 in the
morning and would go till 2:00 in the
morning and [ __ ] like it's it's where
they put a lot of Bank away so he's
obviously not gonna get to do it but
he's working on some cool plans for May
the 4th as well so yeah that's coming up
soon we got a new fake holiday to enjoy
Ralph that's right
and lastly speaking to Universal they
have announced lastly what are you
talking about
the hell good man otherwise we gotta go
watch that gaga
in terms of the headlines that I wanted
to talk about was announced they're
officially teaming up with Amasa
entertainment to bring us a new Green
Hornet and Kato feature film all the
contracts have been signed the t's have
been crossed the eyes have been dotted
and they go into production as soon as
of course all this madness lifts but
they got the trendle family on board and
everybody is squared away so Universal
Pictures will be bringing us the next
Green Hornet film commend us the last
green where it's owned a Sony did so
right I believe I spoke too soon yes
you're right there is a Sony book
picture yeah
in Augusta now this one will be better
it's so weird in an alternate timeline
there's a Green Hornet movie that I made
they last time I read that comic book
that they turned your screenplay into
that comic over there at was it time in
their drink
dynamite it's it's ridiculous that no
one made that film because it's such a
great great script number one thank you
number two it just it was before comic
it was in that period where people like
comic book movies I mean Batman and
Robin died like it was in that period
before Marvel before [ __ ] Dark Knight
or anything like that so it was gonna be
tough to get made I think but they were
on board with like toys like I sat down
with toy people and [ __ ] as part of the
reason I kind of like step back or I was
I got a lot of direct this because they
had me meet with toy people I met with
the military it was the Air Force
because they have a Hornet jet so they
were like you could put that in the
movie and I literally sat down and met
with military people met with who makes
the black beauty what was that book on
car yeah Lincoln Continental I think
wasn't it
they had that we met with the folks from
Lincoln because they were like this
could be the new black beauty I think it
was Lincoln it was some major car
company man where it's like holy [ __ ]
that kind of let's look like the black
beauty and stuff we're like use this car
and [ __ ] you'll wob wobba
so it was weird there was a
lot of meetings with marketing side and
merchandise side and stuff like that
long before I even had started writing a
script and it kind of made me go like no
no fizzes for me but how I it's a
concept that [ __ ] works like why
wouldn't you have a Green Hornet thing
going on it's been apparently over 10
years since sets I couldn't [ __ ]
believe that I saw like an article where
they were like you know 2011 yeah in
that [ __ ] nuts man or Susan nine
years like nine years ago so you know
it's a concept that totally works it's a
bad guy who's really a good guy like
yeah that's [ __ ] awesome it would be
like you know
hey kids imagine if Darth Vader was
really Luke Skywalker and I recommend
still if you can find back issues of
that runs brand said Navy has the f-18
Hornet cap so it was not the Air Force
is the Navy how dare you sir hey man I
don't ever want to have a B I do patting
dishonor our seamen come on I love
seamen I love I love also I recommend
people if they if they can find back
issues of the Green Hornet thing that
you did it's just it's a great take on
that character and the and the lineage
of those characters but also just
because it came to mind I felt the same
way when they announced they were gonna
do a six million dollar man movie when I
read your script that that dynamite
turned into a book for that too I
thought that was really really the one
they should have gone with so then Nicky
over the dynamite live at the comics
like Dyna he was started dynamic forces
used to be like you can get sign copies
and [ __ ] cool comics with exclusive
covers and [ __ ] one day he was like
[ __ ] I'm a publisher and stuff and he
started publishing comics he was the one
that spearheaded that he was like you
know I've got which one went first I
think the green no yeah the Green Hornet
one first yeah and he was like you know
do you want to do the Green Hornet and I
was like I had a movie script
that you know I think maybe he was the
one that was like what about your old
movie script for the Green Hornet movie
what happens with that and I was like I
don't know I guess it belongs to you
know whoever paid me to write it I think
no Miramax paid me to ride it but so I
guess they had to get it from Miramax
that's right hmm
they were like Nikki's like I'm gonna go
in and ask him if I can like get the
script like give him a few bucks and
turn the script into a [ __ ] comic
book and I was like Oh that'd be fun and
he did and then Phil Hester broke the
script down into panels and stuff and my
god
it was I got to see it come to life on
the page but it was thanks to Nick going
in there and like presenting something
that they you know they're programmed to
say no to because it's like that's a lot
of work for a couple thousand dollars
but it worked with Green Hornet and then
he did it with Universal and got my old
bionic man script six million dollar
Massacre the only caveat on both was
that I was not allowed to make money on
those comic book adaptations on the
scripts because I'd already been paid
because I'd already been paid Green
Hornet as a script and I'd already been
paid right six million dollar man is a
script so the studio both studios in
those instances saw it as a way to get a
little bit of money back from those
projects or whatever so you know I was
like oh that's fine normally you get
like a hundred or two hundred dollars a
page in comics at 22 pages that's forty
four hundred dollars
so I forget how many issues Green Hornet
was but it wasn't like you know this
will pay universal back for all the
money they paid me or whatever [ __ ] so
at the end of the day it was still
mighty nice of the corporate lawyer
folks to what you know spend what I'm
sure they felt like was a waste of time
going like what this old dead movie is
somebody's gonna make a comic book
who the [ __ ] read they could have been
total dicks about it yeah but weren't
and Nicky got to make those two series
men and I as the guy who wrote those
scripts that would have just died
someplace got to see them come to life
and people like you and like for you to
go like I'm Ison read that com
that would have been good wouldn't
happen without Nick and dynamic forces
and dynamite commas
I guess though it makes sense because
like said it's a chance for the the
studio to recoup at least a little bit
of money on something otherwise just
sitting in a drawer somewhere so what
they should do that more
I agree a hundred [ __ ] percent what
I'm hoping for is and you know the time
might be right Thanks right now is the
time to be making animation because when
we all go back to work they're not gonna
let us go back to work like we're not
going to be able to do Babylon for an
audience of 200 for a long [ __ ] time
and production wise they don't want a
bunch of [ __ ] 50 hundred people on a
[ __ ] set standing all close to each
other god forbid you got to shoot a
[ __ ] crowd scene and [ __ ] yep so what
is the easiest cheapest [ __ ] Hey we
don't need anybody doing anything it
[ __ ] like that that can't be done
remotely cartoons animation yeah and
wait why did I bring that up because of
old scripts that are sitting in a drawer
somewhere I was saying they should draw
and pull them out and start producing
them yes that's a way to do it animate
them and step out because my Superman
script I'm hoping one day more like the
DC Warner Brothers animation you know I
know they're tying up this run of that
animation like I think Justice League
dark they said is the end of it and
stuff but the next like ran out like I
hope they make that they've you know
made some weird projects it'd be fun to
make mice my old ass 1996 Superman
script as an animated version you get
Nic Cage do the voice and [ __ ] like that
oughta be tight that'd be great
fingers crossed let me do a quick plug
right here the Lego Shazam movie is
either out or coming out this I saw your
name it's out it's I said well maybe
it's not out but I saw the on my iTunes
listing I saw the Lego Shazam but we
have pretty sure it's out and i clicked
on okay man I saw the cast name and your
[ __ ] name was on my TV all huge I was
like I know that
[ __ ] guy yeah I play the wizard
Shazam in that and had a great time
doing it and its really good so I
recommend people check that out as well
I don't get a chance to plug [ __ ] very
often but there you go
especially with all this Corona going
around you and plugging [ __ ]
that's right first I got my dick wet
it's incredibly awkward we're some hot
water on it your [ __ ] pig we haven't
done for a while I don't know how this
is gonna go over in this format but I
thought it would be fun because people
are still sending these in all right you
ready I am ready all right Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big how big is it
even when Babylon was away its presence
was still felt I thought that was nice
and someone sent that good man as
sentimental it made me feel good
press these are all topical Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big how big is it
it contracted COBIT 19 in China while
Liam was in a - right there right
another don't start again I've got to
pick my waitress just came over and told
me if we're doing a bug and Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] I've got a total up my
bill and settle up right now before they
tossed me out of the improv so hey check
one second I'm just paying my server and
now back to the show
alright Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big how
big is it doctor foul Qi says it's a
ping demmick Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big how big is it
Liam wraps it around his face before he
goes out shopping oh my god the ultimate
face mask ultimate Matt and you could be
like didn't getting two things done at
once cuz it's like covering you but
you're also like
be sure you would think of that honestly
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big how big is
it no one can ever be socially distant
from it
Oh oh my god how terrifying and funny
and true ladies and gentlemen of
Hollywood have you had a good time this
evening he did not thank you enough for
coming out but there is no show without
the man sitting next to me give it up
for mr. Ralph [ __ ] Garmin and let's
please give your love to my bestie Babel
brother mr. Kevin Smith and that is
Hollywood babble-on to this week kids
I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman babble
the [ __ ] off and wash your hands good I
Dollywood
[Music]
goodbye everybody thanks everybody have
a great Saturday night see you brother
bye sir fun stuff man
you